we all know how it feels when you see
someone across the room your eyes meet
and everything slows down for a minute
your medial prefrontal cortex plays a
big role in your initial attraction to
someone and it judges physical
attractiveness in just milliseconds does
your heart flutter when you see your
crush the adrenal gland causes the
hormones adrenaline epinephrine and
norepinephrine to be pumped for your
blood in turn your heart beats more
quickly or maybe you get butterflies in
your stomach
this happens when adrenaline is sent to
your lungs muscles and brain this also
directs blood flow to those areas with
not a lot of blood left for your stomach
dopamine is also the reason you feel so
good tests show that love has a similar
effect on dopamine levels as taking
drugs such as cocaine sometimes we get
obsessed or fixated on our new love
couples who have recently fallen in love
I have significantly lower levels of
serotonin this is also experienced by
people with obsessive-compulsive
disorder which may explain why you can't
stop thinking about your new boo falling
in love can be stressful though cortisol
a stress hormone is higher in people who
have recently fallen in love but over
time kissing your loved one will lower
your cortisol levels one study even
found that being married will lengthen a
man's life by seven years and a woman's
by two years